in this story from the post-millennial
Teen Vogue says Biden and Democrats are
losing gen Z support claims they may not
vote at all I'm sure all the Republicans
would absolutely accept either they
don't vote or they vote for Trump then
we have this from vox.com what uh what
Democrats panic over young voters misses
okay sure whatever the point is even Vox
is acknow is is acknowledging Democrats
are starting to freak out cuz more and
more polls are coming out that somehow
a 77-year-old republican white man has
garnered majority support among the
youth vote believe it it it it has been
throughout my life the youth vote is
always a bunch of naive young Democrats
that's how we got Obama yeah Obama's
like you vote for me I'm gonna not blow
kids up and then I was like okay sounds
good to me and they like and then as
soon as he got in he was like H psych
blow them up too many of them I can
believe it it's super believable because
I just see a lot of the young kids their
whole like their whole culture is like
based like I see a lot of them just the
most average kid they like being based
and being based is kind of like being
what conservatives would consider like
you know un not well not unhinged but
they really don't give a f about what
they say yeah it it's the most off ofall
things that's considered Bas liberals
would not approve of and majority of you
like Bas culture there's this video of a
young woman where she's like looking in
the mirror holding up her phone and she
she's talking about how like oh you got
offended because I said something well
that's too effing bad I love that you
shared that yeah it's like it went viral
young kids are seeing that kind of
content mocking the woke going viral yes
they want to get followers I watched one
video where so some of it's super cringe
I'm sorry guys I get it you're young
you're trying to find your shtick and
it's like this one dude every single
video is him sitting in his car
screaming I like that guy and he sounds
like Gody yeah he's just like why is it
that all my I'm like okay like I get it
it's like he's he's people are trying to
do you mean the guy that sounds like
Gilbert godfried it might be I don't
know but it's like a younger guy they're
all trying to find their stick and so he
does this thing where he's like why is
everything so
expensive what's yeah what's happening
and he's like I'm not a Republican or a
Democrat and I'm like you're a
republican the moment you say I am not a
Republican or a Democrat you're a
republican that's those are the rules I
didn't make them up unless you're Oliver
Anthony and then you're just irrelevant
all of a sudden yeah that was
interesting right he's just he I mean
talk about one hit wonder well the thing
he actually had handful of really great
songs I mean they were not bad songs I
think the issue with him and he's
probably still enjoying a lot of success
look just because you know the one song
was the biggest song in the world at the
time he's he's he found a stable base of
support and you just don't see him
because you're not a country music folk
fan and he had like a baby stuff too
right like he might not be sure but I I
will say this he was really just a
regular guy who did not understand that
when he came out saying like I'm not you
know political he was telling all of the
people who promoted him back off mhm
yeah so congratulations we all backed
off for sure also Democrats are always
like I am Progressive I am a feminist
like they they want you to know what
their labels are whereas it's it's
activists for their whole every aspect
of their lives and they wear it as their
whole identity right whereas like you
think for yourself you might lean sort
of conservative you might think of
yourself as a Libertarian like if you
have to look at me and say like oh well
I'm not either one then you're already
not in the pool of people who probably
hate you well and the thing too with the
with um oh you were going to say
something D I'm sorry I was just going
to say I think these po kind also
exemplify the amount of propaganda that
Democrats push out because in the summer
of 2023 I don't know if you remember one
of the main things they were pushing in
their campaigns was Joe Biden had a lot
of the Gen Z behind him he was hiring a
lot of democrat uh influencers as well
like Harry Sisson and other young ones
Chris Mari and like this black guy I saw
it was like eight young influencers came
out of nowhere in the summer all of them
had the same message almost copy and
paste say j z loves Joe Biden Jen Z
loves Joe Biden they would do it about
two times every about every three days
and they just started to vanish off you
can see that their audience has just
withered away so I can definitely see
they were pushing that propaganda super
hard because they probably had these
numbers before the general public right
like cist is just gone I haven't seen
that guy and it's just so much it's just
propaganda and it was they were huge
when they came out and it seems like
okay maybe Biden do have geny and it
just shows I mean I think these polls
just a few months after the summer
should just show people to give it some
time over anything that Democrats say
you think Biden was basically trying to
convince J he was trying to convince
them cuz they I think they had those
numbers I think with the resources that
B has he was tipped off that hey it
ain't looking good turn the ship and
that's why they brought Harry and all
the other propaganda and it still didn't
work he was getting ratio nonstop it was
it was sad you know some of it has to do
with the I got Gaza thing Trump is one
of the most Punk Rock presidents we've
had in a really long time and what I
mean by that is clearly he is not punk
rock in the pure sense of what punk rock
is what I mean is the fact that he's
willing to insult people on TV make fun
of people for being fat punk rock in the
sense of screw you you know you know
what's really funny
B right exactly go back to 1990 Donald
Trump is the embodiment of f you I won't
do what you tell me and rage rage on
behalf of the machine has become the F
you you better do it we tell you so I I
kind of imagine if you're a young person
and you had all these people telling you
to be woke or else and then Donald Trump
is laughing and just pointing at the fat
kid making fun of him you're like that's
fun yeah irreverent I can do what I want
to do leave me alone Democrat somehow
has created their own problem it sad
just through censorship and the forcing
of all of the ideologies it just isn't
natural these kids they got common sense
they hate it like their teachers push
this stuff when you have
teachers Pride ribbons on everybody and
teachers saying like let's all discuss
our pronouns you can't joke about it
like imagine being kid to make unol
fastest way to make it unol kids don't
think that what their teachers want to
do is cool know like my son came home
with some stupid assignment about how
you have to the assignment was to do a
biography of a scientist that was not
white or male what he was like he was
like white male that's who we're doing
and I was like what the hell is this and
he was like I don't know Mom this is so
stupid like New York or West Virginia
West Virginia
Tim I've been saying Cassandra's been
warning about this this is why it's so
important we're trying to do with West
Virginia in Martinsburg because these
woke leftists are it's a cult and they
they move in lie about their views get
elected to positions and then start
injecting this stuff into the schools
that's right there was another thing
that happened a little bit before winter
break where a group came in to talk
about suicide prevention and started
handing out the number for the Trevor
Project the Trevor Project which is like
we're going to trans your kids yay you
know that's their whole Jam because
that's who they think is is committing
suicide when actually it's young white
males who are committing suicide right
the group that the TR project wants to
isolate or alter you know fundamentally
I think that's the craziest thing we we
can acknowledge that suicide is a huge
problem but when you look at the numbers
they don't want to talk about who's
actually committing suicide and that's
that's sad and it is yeah it is and it
is mostly like young men and it's it's
terrifying because you know we need our
young men yeah I find extremely
concerning that the Democratic audience
don't really talk about the suicide
rates of transgenders when they are the
main people that enable them I mean you
would think they would care about all
aspects of their
well this this is one of the most
important things that I think needs to
be talked about in the uh in the whole
issue of the the gender ideology stuff
the first thing I'll say is with the
news being Shan Strickland that what the
woke left has done pink news for
instance they said that Shan Strickland
said being trans is an infection he
quite literally didn't he said the weak
man who is an ally is an infection he
didn't say anything about trans people
he's actually talking about the
journalist but the issue I see is the
first what I saying earlier is I got no
issue with trans people I have an issue
with people who are pushing people
towards dangerous medical practices well
are pseudo medical practices which can
result in a loss of life so uh for
instance when we had Lance from the
surfs on I said that I believe there is
a trans genocide and it's the left that
is pushing it and I stand by that
they're trying to sterilize or the the
things they're offering up to trans
people to a great degree sterilize them
and that will prevent them from having
children genocide doesn't just mean you
go and you kill a bunch of people one
component of genocide would be to
sterilize them sterilization and
Eugenics and so what's happening now is
you have a young person who's suffering
gender dysphoria and they immediately
jump to let's give them irreversible
drugs and surgery which will prevent
them from having families in the future
it seems like some ISS like for whatever
reason they want to do this maybe it's
because they're misguided maybe it's
because they're evil but as you referenc
suicide the point I made was if the
suicide rate of uh trans individual
suffering suffering from uh gender
dysphoria is around 48% I believe right
is that the number 40 to 50% but the
desistance rate at at best for Trans
children is
65% some it could be as high as like 95%
or whatever that would mean that
Democrats are increasing the probability
of suicide in children because if you
leave the child alone there's a two to
one chance they desist and they and and
they and they they they uh puberty cures
them of their dysphoria mhm they then
push them to transition giving them a
50/50 chance of dying which means the
greater chance of survival is leave them
alone this is according to the studies
that are available right now from the
from the major academic institutions why
then are they pushing it I think they're
evil and they make money off of it right
it's it's more effective to have someone
who's suffering and dependent on the
medical system I think ultimately it's
uh they victims right and if if like
we're talking about teenagers being
defiant so if you're a teenager who goes
through surgery who goes through what
whatever your body's permanently
disfigured some might come out and say
like no this is wrong but a lot of them
will just suffer but then also feel
threatened and say like no no no you
guys don't understand I just have to
keep trying I have to keep pushing it
becomes this thing and they are trying
to build people who will eventually
support this movement because they know
that to admit that they were wrong is
ultimately to say that they have made
the worst decision someone could make
and admit you wrong I mean I mean the
opposite it's the opposite of submission
is not even admitting it so that is a
submissive type of person that they're
building regardless cuz if they can't
stand for themselves there
it is a it is a low it is a low um
suicide rate even in the trans Community
a study this is from leor in the City
Journal which I've referenced uh a bunch
of times from last spring a UK study
found that the suicide rate among Clinic
referred transgender identified youth
was
0.03% or four deaths out of 15,000
gender distressed minors in the US where
between 2.1% and 99.1% of Youth now
identify as trans and where rates of of
diagnoses of gender dysphoria have
skyrocketed we are told the numbers of
trans kids have always existed in which
case why Haven we seen a suicide now
what's the what's the suicide rate for
Trans adults uh I don't know you want
pull pull that one up because uh either
we're dealing with false statistics the
argument being that suicide rates are
really high and that's what we're trying
to prevent that's what Jack dorsy said
to me on the Jan podcast or the issue is
that kids who are suffering from gender
dysphoria have an extremely low suicide
rate and the argument for them to
receive this uh uh surgery or or uh
medication is based on false a false
premise it says uh this is the Williams
Institute I'm not super familiar with
this it's out of UCLA it says 44
reported suicidal ideation 7% suicide
attempt and 21% non-suicidal
self-injury over their lifetime well
what's the percentage what's the suicide
percentage uh 42% have attempt Ed it 56%
have engaged in nonic we'll clarify then
attempted suicides at 42% for Trans
adults meaning these kids don't if that
data is correct these kids are not
trying to do this right but if they
become adults that that that actually is
the point I'm making you are increasing
the likelihood they will attempt suicide
by putting them through these
transitions thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net censored membersonly shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time